una crisis galopante que obliga a los
médicos y profesores argentinos a vivir
al día sin posibilidades de un cambio a
la vista y la verdad trato de dividir el
día a día Busco precios recorro mercados
este
buscamos buscamos donde están más barata
la carne donde está más cara más barata
la verdura
uno va jugando con las promociones
online viste y así uno se va moviendo
Argentina Lleva años lidiando con una
elevada inflación 2022 cerró en un dato
del 95% anual y este año podría
acelerarse a pesar de las medidas del
gobierno de Alberto Fernández Voy
comprando semana por semana porque ya no
hago una compra grande y bueno y lo veo
y hay cosas que dejo de comprar digo no
esto es imposible que aumente así
no lo compro cambio los hábitos o compro
ofertas El Banco Central ha subido las
tasas de interés al
75%, lo que ha ocasionado que los
argentinos duden de la buena gestión del
presidente peronista del centro
izquierda de Cara a las elecciones
generales de octubre donde la oposición
conservadora va por delante en las
encuestas los argentinos están hartos de
la inflación y muchos culpan a la mala
gestión económica y a la impresión de
dinero por parte del gobierno en el 2001
te dejaban trabajar ahora con el tema de
importación
cerrado muchas partes no pueden trabajar
ni siquiera O sea a nosotros mismos nos
pasa también en nuestro rubro porque
entre impuestos pago de acá pago de allá
te ahogan y no te dejan trabajar en
Argentina el costo de los alimentos la
gasolina y los servicios supera con
creces el de los salarios por lo que es
cada vez más difícil subsistir en el
país suramericano